[Music]
disaster after disaster and biden
peddles faster
yes says old joe toodles on his schwinn
americans take it on the chin
the president spent the weekend
vacationing in delaware apparently the
only place where he won't get lost
he enjoyed a beachside bike ride
ignoring reporters as he whizzed on by
he's just like lance armstrong except
there's no drugs that'll enhance his
performance
thank you
nice
now aside from the buzzards circling
above him
white is not the only one who enjoys the
beach
taliban terrorists snap these vacay
picks trading in tanks for pedal boats
at a lake that's popular with horny
spring breakers
and we do mean horny since the bikini
babes were all sheep
they remember they remembered to pack
sunscreen speedos and assault rifles
which you know was the original name for
life liberty and levine
one hopes with their new love of water
can soap be far behind for the taliban
but back to biden
according to bob woodward's new book
peril top aides have tried to shield him
from long interviews and unscripted
events and by long they mean anything
that cuts into his pudding time
they call the effect a cocooning of the
president which protects biden from
tough questions and children from being
sniffed by joe biden
by the way cocoon was an 80s movie about
old folks starring wilfred brimley who
was 26 younger than joe biden is now
i didn't get a laugh meanwhile the
growing border crisis in del rio only
worsens and according to the polls our
country is as divided as robert shaw at
the end of jaws
some unifier
no wonder even biden's media defenders
can't do their jobs
so what does joe biden do about this and
and what he has done so far yeah hasn't
really worked well one of the things you
hear him doing frankly is redefining
what unity means the blunt reality is
that's not happening i think he's got a
a pretty big credibility crisis on his
hands because all of these problems in
some ways
showed up after he said
something basically the exact opposite
it's got a lot of work to do
oh that chalk todd i changed his name to
chalk todd
what do you think
thanks
joe you heard the man get to work what
say you
look look look i promised to be the
unity president and i'm delivering all
right as long as you get your
vaccination
and you wear your mask
and you voted for me
and you don't live in one of those red
states we're good to go
everybody else
you know i'm beginning to lose my
patience
okay
so unity everybody it's on the money e
pluribus unum you know what that means
do everything i say
all right
pyrus is bride's advantage that he has
so many crises that we cannot focus on
just one
no everyone's focusing on all of them at
the same time
that's why he's riding a bike
it looks like a late night tv like
murder she wrote like he's showing
himself riding bikes and typing on a
typewriter and
gardening and doing all the things
around the house except the entire
world's exploding around him
another thing i find interesting is
pasaki
every time she talks
um she always talks about his vast
experience in these situations he's been
doing this for over 50 years
so what has he got to say yes he should
have some really good stories like you
know in 1985 this happened and we
handled it this way or in 1997 this
happened or in 2000 or in 1814 when i
got my first pair of shoes
after slaying the dinosaurs but we're
not hearing anything
that is such a great point
no years of experience
sometimes you do things for 50 years and
you just get tired of it
but it's also the pageantry that they
did 50 years ago
we got it on tape now not on tv it's
actually on your phone never mind it's
not on tape that was like 30 years ago i
would be okay if he said google me
like google me in 85 that's the answer
like give us something but but whenever
you have some old guy at work who's a
consultant or something like that rob
you remember this sure or you might be
one yeah but
like at least he goes you know back when
we worked on you know the the sketch
bursum show
we did this we had a yoko ono shows up
with a hatchet
you know we did we let her swing the
hatchet highest rated show ever yeah if
people didn't like her then they loved
her then they loved it but so it's like
he's like the consultant with no stories
well he he may not remember
all of the things that happened but also
the the the to me with the strangest
thing about it is that like there's this
weird blip on the weekend where everyone
didn't get a note and so they were kind
of telling the truth on those sunday
shows yes
i i just hold don't hold your breath i
think sunday they're going to be back in
line sunday will be like i don't think
we recognize the complexities of the
border crisis right
like a lot of complexities in
afghanistan and the border crisis they
didn't exist
four years ago
now they're complicated that's they're
gonna they're gonna get the
that's an anomaly it's like you're
watching the matrix when they say oh if
you have a deja vu it's the matrix
having a hiccup right when you're on the
sunday talk shows and people like cnn
reporters are saying things like i think
biden's messing up that's the blip
they're gonna fix that
they're gonna fix it good point you know
uh kat to put this in kind of your world
hearing chuck todd say such negative
things about biden it's like your
boyfriend testifying against you in
court
i can do better what okay uh
to put things in my world because i am
vapid and only think about boyfriends
would be
it's like when your boyfriend ghosts you
and you want to hear from him more i do
feel like that about joe biden really i
do want to hear what he has to say
because he never talks we don't hear
from remember trump was just doing
rallies just because he wanted to
and everyone was trying to be like stop
talking so much the more you talk the
more stuff that you can say than get you
in trouble i would like to see one joe
biden rally like if our ratings are good
now imagine if he was doing rallies he
just we deserve a joe biden rally no
prompter
no prompter put him up there just let
him go for like an hour it's not gonna
work our show runs at 11.
be like at four o'clock yes there's no
way he's in bed by six there's no way we
can do it from him in his with he can be
in bed we can trick him by setting his
clock ahead by five hours
i see i used to do that to my parents
got my dad fired never was the same kc
[Laughter]
do you have any advice for the president
wow how much time do we have craig
um to your point i think when the sunday
shows the people who did literal mental
gymnastics to prove to us that he was
the hero that we needed are now flipping
the coin on this
i think that maybe um it's sticking with
the script
um and maybe less ice cream and sniffing
and bike rides and and those virtual
we're good we're good right have a great
weekend
kamala harris is flipping coins at
college football games over the weekend
yeah that's true that's true that was uh
what what game was that does anybody
watch that game why look at me i don't
know
all i saw was the coin flipping
it would have been nice if it would have
been like oklahoma and nebraska because
then she had been in close to the border
but
i'm sure it was
probably syracuse or something like that
all right
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else